so where else have actually been
interested in the client-side for a long
time when Ajax sort of first got its
initial push when it's got its acronym
back in thing 2006 rails was one of the
first server-side frameworks that said
this is going to be huge and we're going
to do something about that so we put a
JavaScript library straight in the Rails
distribution prototype and we built a
bunch of helpers around that to make it
easier to to create Ajax applications
with rails and today it's almost
inconceivable that you'll build a new
modern web application that doesn't have
some aspect of Ajax in it now some
people go a lot further than just having
some aspects of Ajax in it some people
have their entire application in
JavaScript and just use the backend as a
datastore for that I don't find that
development experience that pleasurable
I have come to tolerate JavaScript now
that there are great libraries and
frameworks like prototype around it to
sort of make it a little bit more
pleasurable but it is still know Ruby
ice ruby is still my first love in terms
of programming languages and however
much you you you paint up JavaScript
it's not going to be that which is which
is fine so from the development side of
things I don't enjoy JavaScript
programming nearly as much or in the
same league as I enjoy Ruby programming
okay fine on the client side of things
like is this better for the user I think
there's something special and appealing
to me about the mix the mix of how the
web is discrete pages and you use
hyperlinks to jump from place to place
and Ajax is sort of sprinkled across to
to make certain common operations hold
faster I tend not to like very heavy
single screen based web applications
they could be fine for some things but I
think the web has this unique category
of applications
that fit into that sort of middle ground
between one screen or any one screen
applications and static web pages and
that's a awesome sweet spot and I think
it works incredibly well for a wide
array of applications and I wouldn't
want them to be any different there are
certainly some people developing for the
web who long for the days at the desktop
application and finally see that now
Ajax is bringing that back well we've
heard that story a lot of times well
first it was Java that was going to do
this applets were going to bring back
the desktop experience and we could get
rid of this nasty HTML and it was flash
that would bring this forward and now
Ajax or anything else like that there's
been so many attempts to bring the
desktop to the web and none of them have
succeeded in becoming the dominant
approach to building web applications
and I think there's a good reason for
that because that's not what users want
like that sweet spot in the middle is is
great and exactly desirable on its own
terms
Google is certainly trying to bring
about the day where you can just have a
dumb computer and everything happens in
the cloud I don't know if that's even
desirable yet I don't know why it has to
be either/or there are certain types of
applications especially information
based or network based applications that
are just great on the web like editing
your say movies or pictures why does
that have to be online why does the act
of doing that itself has to be online if
there's not a big benefit to that then I
don't see any particular reasoning into
forcing it to be there it's fine to have
local applications too and we don't need
the either ours we can take the best of
the web and the best of the
collaboration to that enables and enjoy
that for all those applications whether
that's a good fit and then we can use
the awesome local graphical power and
computing power of a modern computer to
do to do those other heavy things I
think that that split that duality is
just fine